why did you get kicked out of BYU what
did you do I mean it's so easy to get
kicked out of BYU it's like not like
some rebellious thing to be like but I
had sex with my girlfriend in high
school and I hid it for four years for
my mom she was Catholic I wasn't allowed
to have a girlfriend to begin with and
then she was Catholic and Mormons you
know Catholic moments God I got back
into BYU because I went through the
repentance process that was about six
months and then I reapplied got back in
no sex don't you dare oh poor you dude
so many press yeah did you really you
didn't have sex for six months in other
words they threw you out of BYU they had
a sex till marriage until my wedding
night wow after that you did not have
sex to your wedding night correct you
must have been so backed up I mean it
must have been insane you only knew
you've only been with like two women in
your life yeah well the life of a Mormon
is certainly different than uh your
average Joe he was raised Mormon too
yeah 26 for me he's been with one woman
I was a sex cam for 20. why don't you
pick on him wait a second 26 you didn't
have sex until you were 26 and that's it
one one woman I'm a one woman guy what
can I say but let me understand it so
when you're a young man and your
hormones are raging and you have a
girlfriend are there certain things you
can do like can she masturbate you or is
it just no no nothing just kissing maybe
kissing in fact my mom I remember
driving in the car after a Mormon
conference which is where the Prophet
speaks to everybody and then we're on
the drive home and they had talked about
no passionate kissing and she had this
talk with the with the family of boys in
the car and she said you know what
passion he kissed me wrong he said no
she said it's it's called some people
call it French kissing and uh that was a
big No-No oh my God and what what is
with the six months of um of No Sex in
other words they can't check you well I
had to meet with a bishop every week so
I knew okay I'm gonna have to sit in a
room with this guy he's gonna ask me
this so when you have that stranger
sitting knowing that you're gonna meet
with him kind of helps in the moment to
be kind of a buzz kill on the moment
where you're like well I don't wanna
have to tell that guy I don't want to be
a liar because maybe there's a God and
then maybe I won't go to heaven you know
I mean there's a lot of play in that
young kid's mind and it's actually so
terrible
it's crazy what are you gonna tell your
kids I mean okay look there is a certain
value in valuing Sex and not just like
you know hey I'm gonna go [ __ ] everyone
I can get my hands on which a rockstar
can certainly do that's the thing about
I mean Mormonism in general it's like
it's easier for me especially to to
point all the negatives and I've spent
plenty of time doing that but yeah
there's also something to you know I was
raised in Utah
in kind of the heart of Happy Valley
they call it where you know 99 of my
high school was Mormon and the negatives
are pretty obvious but you know the
positives were things like I knew every
single one of my neighbors like
400 people all around I knew their last
names I knew what they liked what I knew
their kids Community the sense of
community is really hard to replicate I
feel like in a purely secular world so
funny how I view things I knew 400 of
all my neighbors and I hated them all so
uh it's horrible it's absolutely misery
foreign